є небезпека що Московський крути можуть
вийти з сухими з води тому що в справі
про здачу Херсону на жаль не фігурує
Московський Кріт Олег полинич якого
затримала Служба безпеки України у
справі про державну зраду не фігурує ще
один діяч Андрій новомов якого затримали
із величезними активами запасами золотом
валютою і Сьогодні на жаль Серби не
віддають цю людину по екстрадиції в
Україну Ну і є інформація про те що
колишнім голову СБУ якого звільнено було
по статті який передбачає
відповідальність за державну зраду так і
не викликали на допит слідчі Я думаю що
тут справа в тих кроках які залишилися у
власних кабінетах і стараються перекрити
своїх колишніх підлеглих а може ще